de vote sur la retraite à 64 ans mais la
Constitution a été respectée dit le
gouvernement est-ce que pour vous ça
pose un problème démocratique oui ça
pose un problème démocratique parce que
quand la représentation nationale ne
peut pas s'exprimer sur un texte dont le
pays ne veut pas donc des gens sont en
grève depuis des centaines et des
dizaines de jours bon déjà on fait grève
partout dans le pays il faut qu'il y a
une sortie de crise démocratique comment
voulez-vous que des gens continuent à se
calmer et à aller à l'apaisement comme
le propose d'Emmanuel Macron s'il y a
pas de sortie de crise la sortie de
crise ça peut pas être circuler il y a
rien à voir on continue jusqu'au bout
les gens demandent à ce qu'on puisse
s'exprimer la veille de la nichiote
cette Français sur 10 dans un sondage
ELAB on dit on veut que les
parlementaires s'expriment mais dans
quel pays on vit pour empêcher les
parlementaires de se positionner sur un
sujet aussi central que la réforme des
retraites qui va décaler de deux ans à
l'âge de départ donc il va priver de 2
ans de vie de deux ans de meilleure vie
les Françaises et les Français de ce
pays nous devons pouvoir voter et
s'exprimer sur ce texte alors je dis la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale de
l'assemblée de pardon de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a LeBron Piva était
critiquée par les oppositions qui lui
reprochent de cette opposé à ce vote sur
l'abrogation de la retraite à 64 ans et
ce qu'elle peut encore présider cette
institution selon vous je crois qu'elle
a montré hier qu'elle était directement
la télégraphie de l'Élysée et qu'elle
prenait ses ordres dans le bureau
d'Emmanuel Macron pour mettre sous
couvert l'Assemblée nationale et
empêcher le vote il y a les bandes Pivet
se comportent pas comme une présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale d'ailleurs dès
qu'elle préside les séances il y a des
incidents ça se passe mal elle elle
envoie des petites piques où elle
reprend les députés de l'opposition donc
elle se comportent pas comme une garante
de l'institution pourtant c'est ce
qu'elle avait dit dès le début de sa
prise de fonction elle avait dit je
serai la garantie je ne suis pas là pour
transmettre la parole du président de la
République mais pour assurer le
fonctionnement de l'Assemblée nationale
ce n'est pas vrai mais je veux dire un
mot parce qu'il y a les brandes piverts
ne la découvre pas au perchoir il faut
se rappeler que sous la mandature
précédente elle était présidente de la
commission des lois c'est elle qui a
enterré la commission d'affaires sur
Alexandre Benalla en 2018 commission
d'enquête c'est elle qui en 2019 à
empêcher l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
commission d'enquête parlementaire suite
aux nouveaux éléments sur Alexandre
Benalla et c'est elle qui en ce moment
est en train d'empêcher une commission
d'enquête parlementaire que nous
demandons sur le fond Marianne suite aux
révélations concernant la gestion de cet
argent public et notamment le rôle de
Marlène Schiappa donc elle est au
service d'Emmanuel Macron elle est pas
au service du Parlement c'est ça qui est
très grave et ce qui s'est passé hier ça
a été dit c'est classé séparation des
pouvoirs qui est quand même garant dans
nos institutions qui permet la
démocratie de vivre aujourd'hui elle
n'existe plus Emmanuel Macron il peut
pas venir à l'Assemblée mais son point
d'entrée il l'a trouvé avec une
présidente qui aujourd'hui exécute la
voix du monarque présidentiel dans
l'hémicycle alors
[Musique]